Can You Really Bust A Gut From Eating Too
Much At Once
Although extremely rare, some people actually
have ruptured their stomachs after eating
too much, and, perhaps not surprisingly, many
did not survive.
When a stomach ruptures, the billions of bacteria
that normally live inside the gut flow out
into the abdominal cavity where they thrive.
The infection that ensues causes acute abdominal
pain, a tensing of the belly muscles, fever,
nausea, bloating and vomiting.
Without treatment with antibiotics, cleaning
of the cavity and repair of the stomach, the
person dies.
So why wouldn’t the person just vomit if
things got too uncomfortable?
As Dr. Rachel Vreeman explains, the individuals
often have “unusual eating habits to an
extent that their bodies’ reflexes no longer
respond as they normally do.
Their bodies’ reflexes have been ignored
or abused for so long that they no longer
vomit at the appropriate time.
And then once the stomach gets to this extremely
distended point, the stomach muscles are too
stretched out to be strong enough to vomit
the food out.”
In one early case, in 1941, a 51-year-old
woman blew out her belly with a “soda bicarbonate
[think Alka Seltzer] after cocktails and a
heavy dinner.”[1] That meal included meatballs,
tomatoes, cheese, bread, potatoes, macaroni,
pie and whiskey.
At least one commentator noted that the “gas
from the fizz . . . apparently stretched the
stomach to its breaking point.”
A similar thing happened to a 71-year-old
woman in 1955.
In 1963, a 40-year-old New York woman, who
had lost 16 pounds in the two months prior
to bursting by strictly following a 1,000
calorie per day diet, suddenly became ill
after eating a corned beef sandwich.
The small meal caused her to experience severe
nausea, but she was unable to vomit, and she
began feeling a sense of impending doom.
Overnight she got worse, and by the next morning,
she was not in her right mind and in severe
belly pain.
She was admitted to Mount Sinai Hospital,
but initial x-rays did not show a rupture,
so she was treated for over a week with intravenous
fluids and suctioning of her stomach.
After 11 days, her condition had worsened,
and they finally opened her up and discovered
a long rip, that appeared to have been there
for quite a while.
The operation was a success and within a month,
she was discharged.
Seeming to afflict women more than men, in
1985 The Lancet reported the death of a 23-year-old
fashion model from a ruptured stomach.
During her last meal (which they were able
to catalogue during the autopsy), the young
woman ate a half-pound steak, one pound of
liver, two pounds of kidney, two eggs, one
cauliflower, 10 peaches, four pears, four
bananas, two apples, two glasses of milk,
two slices of bread and two pounds each of
grapes, plums and carrots.
It should also come as no surprise that bursting
stomachs appears to be more common among bulimia
sufferers.
The Weekly World News reported in 1994 that
an autopsy revealed that a 19-year-old model
Anne-Marie Boules, in a four- to five- hour
period, gorged on 20 pounds of food that consisted
of an entire fried chicken, a dozen chicken
wings, appetizers, fruit cocktails, two pints
of beer, two large roast beefs, three baked
potatoes, a head of cauliflower with cheese
sauce, a loaf of garlic bread, 8 cookies and
a gallon of ice cream before her stomach ruptured.
Prior to her binge, the 5’9″ 110lb.
model had kept her figure trim by eating only
fruits and vegetables, but during her last
meal, she is said to have inhaled the food
so quickly, she apparently swallowed much
of it without even chewing.
Her rupture was sufficiently severe that she
died from internal hemorrhaging within about
20 minutes.
One of the reason bulimics are more prone
to rupture is that shriveled stomachs are
more susceptible to tearing.
In fact, at least four former POWs after World
War II ruptured their bellies after eating
relatively modest meals.
One of these ingested, over an entire day,
only a quart of coffee, a few potatoes, a
half pound of bread and two quarts of soup.
On that note, not all ruptures are caused
by overeating – at least not directly.
In 2011, a 25-year-old woman from Coventry
who had a gastric band (the band is placed
around the stomach and tightened to aid with
weight loss) nearly died when the band slipped,
causing a wound that turned septic.
For the first couple of months, she suffered
from heartburn, vomiting and difficulty swallowing,
but eventually the pain became unbearable.
At the hospital, her surgeons described her
burst belly as “like a jigsaw,” but she
received a transplant and survived.